- Il y a-tu des meubles
que vous avez perdus?
- Tous, tous...
- François Legault
a annoncé une aide bonifiée
40 $ par jour au lieu de 20,
pour les dépenses quotidiennes,
et un remboursement maximal
de 385 000 $ pour les ququququq.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Le coût des matériaux
les coûts pour construire
ont augmenté. Donc, on parle
d'une valeur de reconstruction.
Et
la valeur de remplacement
des meubles.
- Montrez-moi où se trouve
votre maison....................
- Esther Thibault et Monique
Jean vivaient dans une maison
avec une vue imprenable.
est survenu à quelques mètres
de chez elles.
ESTHER THIBAULT
- On était tr
On avait comme l'impression
d'avoir gagné à Loto-Québec.
C'est une partie de ma retraite
qui est là. Moi, j'ai travaillér
me garantir... un bien-être.
Je t'en parle, là, puis ça fait
des bouillons, ici. Mais...
quatre familles qui viennent
d'apprendre que leur maison
ne pourra pas être sauvée.
- Rendu à notre âge, on ps s s ,
ce qu'on a vécu là, puis...
Moi, j'ai pas élevé mes enfants
là, mes enfants...
- Mais tous nos amis sont
alentour. C'est notre...
notre place, hein!
- D'autres, vi
près du trou béant, n'ont
toujours pas l'heure juste.
Si leurs résidences sont jugées
sécuritaires, il n'y aura pasvee
construction. Roxanne Deschênes
et son conjoint cherchent tout
de même un nouveau domicile.
- Non, ça ne me tente pas
que dans 10 ans, 15 ans,
même si on me sécurise en disant
qu'il n'y a pas de danger...eme,
je ne veux plus dormir...
- Des tranches de sol
de 5 à 15 m tout autour
tomber à tout moment.
La solution : adoucir la pente.
DENIS DEMERS, ingénieur,
min. des T
- On va excaver partout sur
le pourtour de la cicatrice
de glissement, ici, mais on va
partir d'un endroit qui est plue
une immense tranche de sol,
en s'approchant progressivement
de la cicatrice du glissement,
que les pelles mécaniques
et les travailleurs progressent,
ils soient toujours en sécurité.
- Les ingénieurs du minis s s se
preuve de grande prudence
en recommandant l'évacuation
d'autant de familles.
au moins 67 pourront être
réintégrées, mais cela pourrait
prendre plusieurs mois.
Ici M
Radio-Canada, Saguenay.